THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT'S "THE STORY."
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
WHEN YOU LISTEN TO NANCY PELOSI
TELL IT, IMPEACHING THE
PRESIDENT IS THE LAST THING SHE
EVER WANTED TO DO.
SHE HADN'T EVEN CONSIDERED IT
REALLY.
UNTIL THE DAY THAT THE NEWS OF
TRUMP'S NORM SHATTERING PHONE
CALL WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE EMERGED IN THE PUBLIC
VIEW.
IT WAS AT THAT POINT IMPEACHMENT
BECAME ENTIRELY INEVITABLE AS A
PATRIOTIC AMERICAN AND PERSON OF
DEEP AND IMPASSIONED,
NANCY PELOSI HAD NO CHOICE AT
THAT POINT, THE DIE WAS CAST.
SHE HAD TO REMOVE THE PRESIDENT
FROM OFFICE IMMEDIATELY.
THAT'S NANCY PELOSI'S STORY.
WE DON'T READ MINDS ON THE SHOW,
SO WE CAN TELL YOU IF IT'S TRUE
OR NOT.
WHAT WE CAN SAY WITH ABSOLUTE
TRIPLE CERTAINTY IS THAT
PERMANENT WASHINGTON HAS BEEN
THINKING ABOUT IMPEACHING
DONALD TRUMP FOR AN AWFULLY LONG
TIME.
IN FACT, BEFORE HE WAS EVEN
ELECTED PRESIDENT, IF YOU CAN
IMAGINE THAT, THEY WERE THINKING
ABOUT IMPEACHING HIM.
CONSIDERING THE FOLLOWING CLIP,
FROM A WOMAN CALLED EMILY
FARKAS.
AN OBAMA APPOINTEE AT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
SHE LED BELIEVE IT OR NOT THE
UKRAINE POLICY.
ALSO AN ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORTER
OF THE HILLARY CLINTON 2016
CAMPAIGN.
FARKAS APPEARED AT A PANEL
DISCUSSION WHICH THANKFULLY FOR
US WAS VIDEOTAPED.
SOMEBODY ASKED FARKAS WHO SHE
THOUGHT WOULD WIN THE ELECTION.
HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE A STRONG SYSTEM
OF CHECKS AND BALANCES AND
ACTUALLY IF DONALD TRUMP WERE
ELECTED, I THINK HE WOULD BE
IMPEACHED PRETTY QUICKLY OR
SOMEBODY ELSE WOULD HAVE TO TAKE
OVER GOVERNMENTS.
I'M NOT EVEN JOKING.
>> Tucker: IF TRUMP WERE EVER
TO GET ELECTED, NOT LIKELY TO
HAPPEN SHE SAID, HE WOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
TO BE CLEAR, WE ARE NOT ALLEGING
THAT EVELYN FARKAS IS PART OF A
CONSPIRACY.
CONSPIRACY SUGGEST SECRECY, AND
WITH FARKAS AND WHAT THE
NATIONAL SECURITY STATE THAT WAS
NOT SECRET, THEY ALL BRAGGED
ABOUT IT.
THEY ALL BRAGGED ABOUT IT FROM
DAY ONE.
YES, DONALD TRUMP IS VULGAR, BUT
THAT'S NOTHING WITH WHY THEY
HATED HIM.
THEY DISAGREED WITH TRUMP
PROFOUNDLY AND DISAGREED WITH
MOST AMERICAN VOTERS ABOUT THE
ISSUES, PARTICULARLY ON THE
QUESTION OF RUSSIA BUT ON THE
QUESTION OF MIDDLE EASTERN WARS.
MORE THAN ANYTHING, THIS IS THE
KEY, THEY COULDN'T CONTROL WHAT
DONALD TRUMP SAID OR DID.
NOBODY CAN.
AND THAT WAS THE UNFORGIVABLE
CRIME.
AND FROM DAY ONE, THEY PLAN TO
TAKE HIM OUT, THIS UKRAINE
NONSENSE IS THE LATEST PRETEXT
FOR DOING THAT.
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF THEM.
RUSSIA, STORMY DANIELS, FILL-IN
THE BLANK BLANK.
IT'S LIKE MAD LIBS.
A STORY IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REVEALS EVERY BIT AS MUCH THAT
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER PRETEXT.
IT TURNS OUT THAT HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN ADAM SCHIFF
KNEW ABOUT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
COMPLAINT BEFORE IT WAS EVEN
FILED.
IN FACT, HE ORCHESTRATED THE
STORY IN SECRET LONG BEFORE YOU
AND I OR ANYONE ELSE IN THE
COUNTRY HEARD THAT.
THE SO-CALLED WHISTLE-BLOWER
CONTACTED SHERIFF'S OFFICE WAS
RECOMMENDED A LAWYER FOR HIM OR
HER.
SCHIFF LATER LIED BRAZENLY.
CLAIM HIS OFFICE NEVER SPOKE TO
THE CI EMPLOYEE DIRECTLY.
HAD TO KNOW THAT ADMITTING THAT
WOULD UNDERMINE THE STORY AND
IMPEACHMENT FOR HIMSELF.
TONIGHT THERE ARE CREDIBLE
RUMORS THAT ADAM SCHIFF HIMSELF
PLANTED TODAY'S BOMBSHELL IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" STORY.
HE KNEW IT WOULD COME OUT AND HE
WANTED THE MOST OF IT PATHETIC
POSSIBLE COVERAGE.
THAT'S THE LINE.
WE CAN CONFIRM THAT.
OTHER WAY, THE STORY THIS
MORNING GREATLY DAMAGES THE